11 months since Russia's brutal
full-scale invasion of Ukraine an 11
months in which Ukrainian people have
showed Putin and the world
a full force of their courage and the
abdominal determination to live free
and through every single step this
horrific War the American people have
been strong and unwavering to the
support and Democrats and Republicans in
the Congress have stood together
the United States has worked on lockstep
with our allies and partners around the
world to make sure you Ukrainian people
are in the strongest possible position
to defend their Nation their families
and against the brutal the truly brutal
aggression of Russia I haven't seen the
likes of this in a long time
the United States and Europe are fully
United
this morning
I had a long conversation with our NATO
allies German Chancellor Schultz friends
president macron prime minister Sanuk
and the Italian Prime Minister Maloney
to continue our close coordination and
their full support of Ukraine because
you all know I've been saying this for a
long time the expectation of the part of
Russia is we're going to break up we're
not going to stay United but we are
fully thoroughly totally United
with spring approaching Ukrainian forces
are working to defend the territory they
hold and preparing for additional
counter offenses
to liberate their land they need to be
able to counter Russia's evolving
tactics and strategy on the battlefield
in the very near term
they need to improve their ability to
maneuver an open Terrain
and they need an enduring capability to
deter and defend against Russian
aggression over the long term
the Secretary of State the secretary of
the uh
military I'd be behind me are they
they've been deeply deeply involved in
this this whole effort armored
capability as general Austin will tell
you to speak
is has been has been critical that's why
the United States has committed hundreds
of armored fighting vehicles to date
including more than 500 as part of the
assistance package we announced last
Friday
and today today I'm announcing that the
United States will be sending 31 Abram
tanks to Ukraine the equivalent of one
Ukrainian Battalion secretary Austin has
recommended this step because it will
enhance the Ukraine's capacity to defend
its territory and achieve its strategic
objectives the Abram's tanks are the
most capable tanks in the world and
they're also extremely complex to
operate and maintain
so we're also giving Ukraine the parts
and equipment necessary to effectively
sustain these tanks on the battlefield
when we begin we'll begin to train the
Ukrainian troops on these issues of
sustainment logistics and maintenance
soon as possible
delivering these tanks to the field is
going to take time
time that we'll see and we'll use to
make sure the ukrainians are fully
prepared to integrate the Abram tanks
into their defenses
we're also closely coordinated this
announcement with our allies
the American contribution will be joined
by an additional announcement including
that will be will be ready to available
more easily integrated for use in the
battlefield in the coming weeks and
months from other countries I'm grateful
of Chancellor Schultz for providing
German Leopard two tanks and will lead
an effort to organize a European
contribution of two tank battalions for
Ukraine I want to thank the chancellor
for his leadership and his steadfast
commitment to our Collective efforts to
support Ukraine
Germany has really stepped up the
chancellor has been a strong strong
voice for Unity a close friend and for
the level of effort we're going to
continue
supporting Ukraine's ability to fight
off Russian aggression to defend its
sovereignty and territorial Integrity is
a worldwide commitment I just looks a
worldwide commitment last week Germany
and Germany secretary Austin convened
Ukraine defense contact group for the
eighth time this group was made up of
some 50 Nations 50 Nations each making
significant contribution of their own to
Ukraine's integrity
he's fully committed to making Ukraine
remain strong and independent and able
to defend itself against Russian threats
and violence
I want to thank every member of that
Coalition for continuing to step up
the UK and the United Kingdom recently
announced that it's donating Challenger
2 tax to Ukraine France is contributing
AMX 10s armored fighting vehicles
in addition to the leopard tanks the
Germany like the United States is also
Germany is also sending a patriot
missile battery
Netherlands is donating to Patriot
missile and launchers France Canada the
UK Slovakia and Norway and others have
all donated critical air defense systems
to help secure Ukrainian skies and save
the lives of innocent civilians who are
literally the target the target of
Russia's aggression
Poland is sending armored vehicles
Sweden is donating infantry fighting
Vehicles Italy is giving artillery
Denmark and Estonia are sending
howitzers Latvia is providing more
Stinger missiles lithuanians providing
anti-aircraft guns and Finland recently
announced its largest package of
security assistance a day you may
remember what was asked a while ago what
I think was going to happen and I said
let to know he thought that he's going
to end up with the fiddleization of
Europe when he's got the natoization of
Finland we've gotten something that he
never intended together with our allies
and partners we sent more than 3 000
armored vehicles
where the 8 000 artillery systems more
than two million rounds of artillery
ammunition and more than 50 Advanced
multi-launched rocket systems and I ship
and air defense systems all to help
counter Ukraine's brutal aggression
that's happening because of Russia
and look today's announcement Builds on
the hard work and commitment from
countries around the world led by the
United States of America to help Ukraine
defend its sovereignty as territorial
integrity
that's what this is about helping
Ukraine defend and protect Ukrainian
land it is not an offensive threat to
Russia you know there is no offensive
threat to Russia if Russia troops
returned to Russia they'll be there for
this where they belong this war would be
over today
that's what we all want an end of this
war
in just and Lasting terms
you know our teams do not permit One
Nation we're not going to allow one
nation to steal the neighbor's territory
by force
our terms
preserve Russia's Sovereign Ukrainian
sovereignty and territorial integrity
and honor the U.N Charter that's our the
terms we're working on
and you know these are these are the
terms we all signed up for in 143
Nations voted for in the United Nations
General Assembly last October so the
United States standing shoulder to
shoulder of allies and partners is going
to continue to do all we can to support
Ukraine
Putin expected Europe and the United
States to weaken our resolve he expected
our support for Ukraine to crumble with
time
he was wrong
he was wrong he was wrong from the
beginning he continues to be wrong we
are united
America is United and so is the world
we approached the one-year Mark as we do
the Russian full-scale invasion of crime
we remain United and determined as ever
and our conviction and our cause
these tanks are further evidence of our
enduring an unflagging commitment to
Ukraine and our confidence and the skill
of the Ukrainian forces
as I told president zielinski when he
was here and today is his birthday by
the way
in December we're with you for as long
as it takes Mr President
crannies are fighting an age-old battle
against aggression and domination
it's a battle Americans have fought
proudly time and again
and it's a battle we're going to make
sure the ukrainians are well equipped to
fight as well this is about freedom
freedom for Ukraine Freedom everywhere
it's about the kind of world we want to
live in the world we want to leave to
our children
so may God protect the brave Ukrainian
Defenders of their country and keep the
flame of Liberty burning bright as we
can thank you Mr President why are you
taking this decision now
did Germany force you to change your
mind on something tanks
they're already didn't force me to
change your mind we wanted to make sure
we're all together that's we're going to
do all and that's what we're doing right
now Mr President any response